[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'es7 fit
sport l'émission est toujours consacrée
à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
basket l'entente le chesnay-versailles
remporté son match retour de playoffs
contre paris 14
une victoire qui permet aux joueurs de
la cité royale de participer au final
four de prénationale les détails dans ce
magazine course plus de 1600
participants ont participé au versailles
traitement festival coup de projecteur
sur l'une des épreuves phares le
triathlon du roi plus d'informations à
suivre
gymnastique les championnats de france
seront programmées cette semaine du 24
au 26 mai au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'occasion pour les spectateurs de
découvrir trois pépites de la jem est en
cours on mord pas reportage l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 68
t les playoffs du championnat de
prénationale en quarts de finale
versailles n'a pas tremblé vainqueurs à
l'aller les versets ils se sont une
nouvelle fois imposé face à paris 14 sur
le score de 81 à 71 à domicile des
images de nicolas landry un montage de
romain respini
un dernier panier de bamba cei à 12
secondes de la fin du match face à paris
14 et l'entente le chesnay-versailles
peut jubiler
le fcb 78 a réussi à éviter une revente
à d'assaut samedi 18 mai sur son tas en
quarts de finale de prénationale
vainqueur 73 à 52 à l'aller les hommes
de la cité royale se sont imposés au
retour 81 à 71 sur leur parquet il
fallait être concentré respecté les
consignes et jeux basques tous les
matches et pour gagner
non même si l'on était à + 21 h 30 donc
l'objectif c'était de gagner l'objectif
c'était véritablement de jouer pour
gagner et surtout pas de jouer pour ne
pas perdre et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
du coup ça a fait un match plein voilà
ils se sont défendus avec leurs armes et
on a encore été plus fort ce soir donc
c'est amplement mérité je pense
avec ce résultat l'entente le chesnay
versailles 78 se qualifie pour le final
four de la division l'équipe affrontera
meudon demi finale sur terrain neutre à
palaiseau pour une revanche
elle veut donner les avait battus au
mois de février dernier en cas de
victoire les joueurs de la cité royale
se verrait propulsé en nationale 3
elana qui à part une place en demi
finale tout reste à faire et on va jouer
notre saison maintenant non plus sur 6
matchs bailar explique 2 donc on le sait
et il va falloir faire le job
bien évidemment ce groupe a le niveau
parce que je sais qu'on aura du coeur et
on le montrera les versailles et auront
deux semaines complètes pour préparer au
mieux ce week-end décisif la
récupération devrait être plus simple
après cette victoire
[Applaudissements]
on continue par du rugby l'incroyable
saison de versailles est terminée les
joueurs de la cité royale invaincu cette
année en 21 matchs ont perdu face à un
autre fc ville rugby-club vesoul sur
terrain neutre en 16e de finale du
championnat de france honneur après
s'être neutralisées sur le score de 23
partout après prolongation les
versaillais ont finalement craqué aux
tirs au but et ne verront pas les
huitièmes
rendez vous en septembre prochain pour
le retour du rcv en fédérale 3 on
continue à parler de versailles mais
cette fois ci en football dans le
championnat de nationale 3 les
versailles et peuvent toujours espérer
monter en fin de saison se sont imposés
à 2 à 0 à domicile face à l'équipe 2 du
paris fc au classement verseille
troisième avec 42 points à 2 points de
la première place détenue par les
gobelins dans le championnat de
régionale 3 trappe à peut-être laissé
passer sa chance de remporter le titre
mais l'équipe a fait un grand pas vers
la montée les trappistes n'ont pu faire
mieux que match nul 1 but partout à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de rueil
malmaison résultat qui leur permet
d'être deuxièmes à une journée de la fin
du championnat le strap conserve trois
points d'avancé sur son adversaire du
jour
il ya un match nul le week-end prochain
pourrait leur offrir à la montée dans le
championnat de d1 de district ont joué
la 21e journée maurepas s'impose contre
le ch est née sur le score de 3-1
montesson domine plaisir dans un match
spectaculaire ponctuée par un 6 à 3 lui
en cours bat le leader marly le roi 3-1
où il ya carrière grésillons se séparent
sur un match nul 3 partout
enfin à gargenville s'impose face au fc
mantois le championnat reste dominé par
marly le roi une dernière information en
football les moins de 15 ans d'elancourt
ont emporté la finale de lorraine jeune
challenger l'orangé football challenge
face au racing club de france
la rencontre s'est déroulée au parc des
princes à la mi temps du match entre
paris dijon le principe les joueurs
devaient marquer dans un face à face en
partant du milieu de terrain les joueurs
ont ensuite assisté au match de ligue 1
et à la remise du trophée des champions
de champion de france seront mis aux pnj
au chapitre course le versailles
création festival est organisé tout au
long du week-end autour de la pièce
d'eau des suisses réunissant plus de
1600 personnes parmi les courses phares
on retrouvait notamment le triathlon du
roi coup de projecteur sur la course des
images de marylène iapichino un montage
de et xavier jaillard 9 heures du matin
pièce d'eau des suisses à versailles 550
courageux équipé d'une combinaison ont
pris le départ du triathlon du roi dans
une eau à 17 degrés
cette épreuve phare au groupe et des
licenciés masculins venu se tester sur
la distance là on est sur une distance
est-ce donc ils viennent de faire 750 m
de natation
ils sont actuellement sur 20 km de vélo
et ensuite ils enchaîneront sur 5 km de
course à pied disputée jusqu'au bout sur
le vélo ou à pied la course s'est jouée
dans le sprint final après une heure
cinq minutes et 8 secondes
brice gayant ancien pensionnaire de
versailles est aujourd'hui à issy
triathlon remporté l'édition 2019
je veux vraiment m'imposer je savais
qu'il y avait des gros clients donc je
me suis pas retournée à vélo j'ai été
tout seuls quoi et c'est passé on est
sorti à trois de l'eau après ils ont eu
un peu de mal à la transition donc j'ai
eu dix mètres j'en ai profité
comme mon point fort c'est le vélo
après après bah je te donner quoi les
autres cours ont terminé beaucoup plus
loin mais avec le sourire course on a
bien roulé il faut faire parcourir donc
je dirais que c'est parfait la nage
toujours un peu compliqué sur le plan
d'eau de versailles nouvel os bien et
ont fermé un peu dans un groupe e qu'ils
voulaient pas de ruling g course à pied
on essaye de donner ce qu'on peut quoi
tous les participants se retrouveront
l'année prochaine les organisateurs du
verset y traite le festival ont déjà
annoncé vouloir organiser une onzième
édition
en boxe la boxeuse de la team farruggia
il encourt marina tollé n'a pas réussi à
créer la surprise à
cosne-cours-sur-loire malgré une belle
résistance
la sportive s'est incliné face à hélène
lacombe pour le titre vacant de champion
de france super coq
les arbitres ont donné vainqueur son
adversaire après huit ans de l'illinois
affiche désormais un bilan de quatre
défaites en cinq combats
il devrait combattre à nouveau avant
octobre un mot de volley ball à présent
pour la troisième fois les villes de
vélizy villacoublay et viroflay ans
accueillis sur cinq jours les
championnats ultramarins et nationale 2
lui délégation outre-mer venu de
guadeloupe guyane martinique et réunion
avaient fait le déplacement ainsi que
huit équipes de nationale 2 en écoute le
président du club de vélizy nicolas gay
niche au micro de notre journaliste
marylène yapi chine on est plutôt
contents ce que c'est un événement qui
perdure sur vélizy ça permet de
réunir pas mal de monde dans les
tribunes
au final outre mer les tribunes étaient
pleines là ça commence à se remplir pour
les finales m2 avec une ambiance sympa
de mobiliser pas mal de bénévoles en
interne et de parler un peu nos clubs et
là il a dit de l'elysée l'équipe de la
réunion tampon gecko volley a remporté
la compétition outre mer on ouvre une
page insolite le jeune thomas d'eric va
tenter un pari fou cet hymne montant de
20 ans a décidé de traverser deux
déserts en bolivie à pied en solitaire
en totale autonomie et sans gps pour
nous parler de ce projet nous recevrons
thomas à derrick sur ce plateau bonsoir
on sur michael alors pourquoi vouloir
tenter ce défi parce que j'ai envie de
découvrir de me découvrir dans l'inconnu
d'aller me challenge est à l'autre bout
du monde d'être dans un désert de voir
ce que ça fait 4 milieu d'une immensité
blanche et d'être tout seul là de
ressentir ce que ça fait alors pourquoi
la bolivie parce que la bulgarie
pourquoi la bolivie parce que c'est pas
spécialement la bolivie c'est plus le
désir en lui-même qui m'intéresse le
salar de uyuni et le salaire de kayes
pas à céder en droit d' donc je rêve
d'aller depuis je suis tout petit et le
fait d'être seul au milieu de ces
endroits de ces déserts mme m'anime me
donne envie d'y aller
vous êtes un passionné de voyages oui je
suis allé à tokyo avec mes parents
pendant cinq ans fait une expatriation
là bas j'ai vécu là-bas j'ai grandi en
voyant en voyageant et en entrant et
toutes supérieures j'ai commencé à
voyager par moi même à prendre mon envol
et l'année dernière j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous pouvez âgées de commencer à
prendre ma tante a baroudé conseil parce
que c'est un besoin
vous avez déjà visité
amérique du sud ou pas du tout mais
c'est la première fois vous avez visité
quoi comme pays par exemple plutôt
l'europe et l'asie comme j'ai dit j'ai
vécu à tokyo donc j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller à bali au vietnam au cambodge à
singapour donc plus tôt l'asie et
l'europe c'était l'été dernier j'ai fait
un fait un tour d'europe en ami j'aime
bien me balader en europe et c'est une
expérience que vous avez déjà réalisé
dans le passé ou ce sera une première
pour vous non c'est là c'est la première
fois ce ski à ses challengers
j'ai déjà voyagé par moi même je pense
que je suis assez aguerrie de ce côté là
mais après sur le plan vraiment partir
dans un désert tout seul c'est vraiment
une première pour moi c'est un challenge
et vous vous entraînez pour y arriver
j'ai pas un programme des spartiates je
n'hésite pas tellement sur le sport je
me prépare psychologiquement j'essaie de
faire de la mentalisation de récolter un
maximum d'informations d'aller sur des
forums d'avoir des avis de personnes qui
sont allées ils l'ont fait dans d'autres
conditions
mais leur retour est intéressant et sur
le plan sportif je fais des randonnées
j'essaie d'habitués mon corps au portage
du sac mais je ne pousse pas plus loin
l'effort physique car je pense que la
difficulté ne sera pas là ce sera
vraiment mental vous entraîner dans ce
secteur
oui je me suis fait des randonnées du
côté de rambouillet j'aime bien passer
dans la vallée de chevreuse et ballades
et le week-end ça sera pas tout à fait
les mêmes conditions j'imagine à ce que
la bolivie
non ce sera un peu plus déroutant là bas
mais
l'effort reste le même marché tout droit
et puisque son cap comment réagit votre
entourage vos amis cette expérience
alors mon entourage n'est pas au courant
j'ai émis j'ai informé quelques
personnes des proches un cercle très
restreint mais j'ai pas encore divulgué
l'information a beaucoup de gens parce
que j'ai pas envie de nous poser afin de
me confronter à aux avis négatif aux
doutes aux peurs
je préfère pour le moment préparé sa
double coin et c'est aujourd'hui
l'occasion de l'annoncé et pour
l'instant c'est les retours sont plutôt
positifs aux personnes avec qui vous en
avez parle c'est on semble inquiétudes
des doutes parce que j'ai jamais fait ça
parce que je suis jeune mais je me
stresse pas je me dis que j'ai quand
même alors vous avez 20 ans voilà j'ai
que 20 ans j'ai toute la vie devant moi
si je leur ai dit je leur ai laisse pas
cette année que ça se passe dans un an
deux ans je ferai à 22 ans
sarr est super jeune cette année j'en
mets le tenter et réussir n'est pas
forcément une obligation ça peut être
revenir plus fort l'année prochaine
et ça n'a jamais été fait à 20 ans j'ai
bien 8 me suis bien renseigné
oui c'est ça ça a été fait une première
fois par un explorateur qui s'appelle
louis philippe loncke un explorateur
belge qui a une cinquantaine d'années
donc il est assez âgée il a de
l'expérience
ça a été trois ans de plus que vous
voilà ça a été fait par d'autres
personnes mais de nos ces conditions la
personne de najlae encore fait
donc vous allez partir avec quoi
concrètement alors on part avec un sac à
dos de l'eau je pense moi
personnellement j'ai envie de je préfère
prendre de la nourriture lyophilisée ça
diminue le poids c'est pas super bon et
c'est pratique et après une tente duvet
et voilà ni boussole ça sera suffisant
je l'espère je l'espère vous avez un
plan b éventuellement si ça fonctionne
pas alors qu'un sac à dos oui mon sac à
dos comme je suis en totale autonomie
j'ai pas de balises j'ai pas tracker
j'ai pas de téléphone satellite
donc j'ai une boussole et moi-même et
nos couples ont baissé finalement je me
dis c'est assez simple je me dis que si
j'entre dans le désert chaud obligé d'en
sortir
après le côté que ce soit allé au bout
revenir en arrière
tant pis j'en sortirai quoi qu'il arrive
mais pourquoi justement pas de gps parce
que rien avoir un sens forcément
l'activer oui c'est vrai mais j'ai envie
de savoir ce que ça fait d'être la base
sans filet de sécurité être vraiment
face à moi même et vous allez faire face
à quelles difficultés
finalement dans des herbes je pense que
ça va être l'expérience en elle même qui
va être déroutante
le fait d'être dans le vide déjà je
pense que le vide va être très dur au
bout de dix heures
il n'y aura pas de distractions
visuelles ces sept là c'est tout blanc à
perte de vue
j'aurais personne à qui parler je pense
que je verse à ses dépenses et puis au
bout d'un moment je vais découvrir ce
que ça fait d'être tout seul face à soi
même
après c'est un désert de sel nucléaire
et abrasifs louis philippe loncke le
premier explorateur qu'il a faits
décrits des phénomènes comme le fait que
vous désirez saigner du nez
donc ça peut être assez particulier ça
peut me donner envie de m'hydrater
encore plus donc je vais devoir gérer
mon dos de manière encore plus
intelligente et après je pense que ça va
être le mental le monte à l'avancé
suivre son cap croire et surtout aussi
je pense que comme le fait que je n'ai
pas de gps je ne vais pas savoir où j'en
suis vingt deux kilomètres j'ai parcouru
par jour donc se dire je suis au milieu
peut-être que j'en ai fait 20
aujourd'hui peut-être que j'en ai fait
disent combien il me reste je ne sais
pas ça peut être assez particulier quand
vous allez faire pour vous repérer du
coup ça sera par rapport au soleil aux
étoiles peut-être alors la boussole je
suis un cap et ensuite il ya le désert
est un volcan qui est assez visible
une fois qu'on a atteint une partie du
désert il faudrait il faut il faudra que
je fasse un peu près la moitié après je
pourrai me repérer à partir du volcan
savoir où j'en suis et évalué à peu près
combien de temps il me reste comme un
temps justement vous allez mettre pour
traversée de désert alors le premier le
salar de uyuni ce serait une diagonale
de 140 km partant gold chagny jusqu'à
lundi qu'à environ six jours sept jours
ci
mais plus de temps que prévu ensuite je
passe a dit kai le désir de cueille pas
à ce serait 100 km donc un total de
douze jours cinq jours et sept jours
donc ce n'est pas trop dangereux
vous nous rassurer on verra ah oui quand
aura lieu le départ
alors je parle d'abord je pars dans un
mois le 16 juin
je commence d'abord par faire des
randonnées au pérou je vais faire la
cordillère blanche et le trac du sale
quand et pour me préparer m'acclimater à
l'altitude aller fort en montagne et
ensuite à partir de mi juillet je serai
dans le désert
ce sera votre dernier défi où ça sera
votre premier ce sera mon premier défi
j'ai énormément de projets dans ma tête
mais qu'il faut déjà que j'arrive à
amener à bien celui-là et ensuite par
exemple par exemple un de mes rêves ce
serait de faire le lac baïkal en patins
à glace
le lac baïkal ses plus beaux grands lacs
du monde en plein hiver il est gelé les
camions peuvent même roulé dessus
sylvain tesson en parle dans son livre
dans les forêts de sibérie et on y rêve
ce serait de traversée de dusudaunord
700 km 14 jours de patin à glace ça
revient quasiment à faire paris avignon
en patins à glace
merci on vous le souhaite en tout cas
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
on suivra votre performance avec
attention et vous reviendrez ici en
plateau pour pour débriefer votre
expérience assez merci beaucoup
on prend maintenant la direction des
terrains de golf le trophée sport
passion créée en 1994 a réuni jeudi
dernier
des personnalités du monde sportif
pendant toute la journée sur les greens
de feucherolles objectif promouvoir des
associations soutenues par le conseil
départemental mais également permettre
aux athlètes de se réunir autour du golf
on écoute les réactions des participants
au micro de tv 78 c'est comme si le
cnosf voiliers avaient organisé un grand
événement entre sportifs d'hiver et
sportif d'été voilà on est en espèces
d'intersaison entre le début de la
saison pour les sportifs des jeux d'été
et puis ceux qui viennent de finir la
saison d'hiver donc je trouve que c'est
bien d'avoir ce rassemblement parce
qu'on l'a de moins en moins et puis
alors surtout quand on est un ancien
athlète de haut niveau on l'a plutôt
donc finalement c'est bien de revoir des
collègues c'est super
c'est bon la nature avec des potes qui
sont coriaces ou pas ils sont coriaces
mais pas sympa bassékou là c'est une
belle ça c'est une belle journée c'est
une belle journée soirée en général ça
se termine cessez le feu c'est top
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
commence cet agenda par de la
gymnastique les championnats de france
seront programmées cette semaine du 24
au 26 mai au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'occasion pour les spectateurs de
découvrir trois pépites de la jem est en
cours mort pas un montage de jules grevy
elles sont revenus tout les trois
médaillés des championnats de france
individuels le 12 mai dernier à nice 17
ans ailier et hyaline 14 ans sont trois
gymnastes yvelinoise formé à l'aj m et
l'on court mort pas un club qui les a vu
éclore des filles qui ont beaucoup de
talent
on essaye dans la mesure du possible de
développer encore plus ses talents mais
pour faire ce qu'elles font il ya il ya
des qualités innées même avec du travail
on pas les avoir ça fait déjà presque 20
ans que j'entraîne
j'ai vu passer pas mal de gymnastes et
des gymnases avec autant de talent aussi
bien physique mental il n'a pas beaucoup
pour continuer à progresser les trois
pépites qui sont au club depuis
plusieurs saisons s'entraînent entre 12
et 20 heures par semaine sur ces agréé
au gymnase du bois à maurepas et tout
cela dans un esprit familial la
politique du club
je pense que ça joue parce que quand
quelqu'un enfin par exemple ça va moins
bien sur la séance à seront là pour me
motiver ou m'encourager
moi pareil c'est le serment d'un souci
on se retrouve avec des filles ont même
pas enfin vraiment envie de s'entraîner
du coup on prendra ce moment
un esprit familial qui est associé à
l'exigence du haut niveau objectif pour
les coaches repousser toujours plus
leurs limites au niveau l'action des
hanches haut niveau l'action des épaules
c'est encore plus petits elles peuvent
encore faire mieux
peuvent durcir les mouvements faire des
mouvements on va être compliqué plus
long plus propres au site c'est une des
qualités de la gymnastique c'est le côté
artistique donc il faut de l'exécution
parfaite si on veut voir des bonnes
notes et donc des médailles
prochain rendez vous pour ces pépites
les championnats de france par équipes
qui seront organisées du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les trois amis auront à coeur de
remporter des titres devant leur public
un autre rendez vous qu'il ne faudra pas
manquer ce week-end les internationaux
de boxe française ainsi qu'un open de
canne de combat seront organisées ce
samedi à partir de 14h à viroflay au
centre sportif gayant pour nous parler
de ce rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce
plateau pedro da à gloria président de
la section boxe française de l'ufm
viroflay ainsi que julien un modèle un
moniteur de cadres de combat bonsoir
bonsoir
alors avant de parler de l'événement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
ses cannes de combat qu'est ce que c'est
il vous en avez avec vous justement là
donc c'est un bout de bois le 95 cm en
châtaignier la canne de combat en fait
c'est une sorte d scream avec son
histoire ses traditions et sa propre
codification à la différence de l'escrim
manière classique on va ni tranché ni
piqué on va respecter un principe
d'efficacité qui veut que tous les coups
soit armé et exécutée avec le maximum
d'amplitude ça donne un côté
naturellement esthétique et très ample
c'est ce qu'on va rechercher et ensuite
il ya aussi un principe de priorité à
respecter il ya six attaques de base 8
parade à ceci on va dire aux attaques de
base s'ajoutent des voltes détour sur
soi offensif ou défensif c'est plus
mobiles que les scream 1 qu'envoyer
effectivement
au niveau de l'espace qui est utilisé ça
se passe sur une aire circulaire 2,9 m
de diamètre donc le la liberté de
mouvement est total et donc on n'est pas
effectivement focaliser sur un couloir
également à la différence de l'escrim on
n'est pas latéralisé c'est à dire qu'on
va utiliser autant à main droite que la
main gauche ce qui donne énormément de
possibilités et de combinatoire et de
richesse si vous voulez à l'exécution
des coûts et au déroulé de l'assaut
parlez nous de cette can du coup
pourquoi vous avez déjà de taille
différente
alors oui alors vous avez la can 95 cm
120 grammes à peu près qu'on tient à une
main on peut également pratiquer à
double cannes et là on peut aussi avoir
un travail très riches et développés
l'adresse des ongles âge etc on a aussi
le bâton qu'on pratique on va dire de
manière parallèle où là qu'on va tenir à
demain celui ci fait un mètre 40
il ya d'autres styles de combat au bâton
mais celui ci fait un mètre quarante
aussi en châtaignier pour à peu près 400
grammes voilà c'est un travail qui est
complémentaire et parallèles en fait à
celui de la can directeur reprend aussi
les codifications c'est une discipline
qui était un peu tombé dans l'oubli
il faut le dire elle était très
populaire au 19ème siècle
c'est pourquoi les tombées dans l'oubli
justement est pourquoi depuis quelques
années ça revient alors la guerre
mondiale est passée par là également au
19e siècle c'était un accessoire de mode
tout le monde portait une canne comme
chacun ici et maintenant un smartphone
et donc ses revenus en fait également
avec l'essor d'avec le régisseur de la
boxe française
pendant des années on va dire 60 70 par
un monsieur qui s'appelait maurice harry
qui était un ami du fondateur du club de
viroflay dans lequel on officie et
nous c'est à ce moment là en fait que
l'as cannes voilà revient et se
redéveloppe à partir des tracts et
effectivement des dix neuvième siècle
synthèse de ce monsieur qui s'appelait
maurice 1 donc c'est une discipline qui
est associé à la boxe française
oui pourquoi honnêtement depuis le début
cette sortie comme ça tout dans des ans
dans les tuyaux club au 19e siècle on
enseignait la can le bâton en escrime
gymnastique et la boxe française cette
fois et est complémentaire de la banque
116 est par tradition qui s'est un peu
perdu d'ailleurs tout boxeur faisait de
la can pratique à la can moi même j'ai
pratiqué cannes à mes débuts
notre jean pierre lebon aux professeurs
nous enseigner la can c'était habituel
l'amérique alors je viens un mode l'un
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de vous
lancer dans cette discipline
alors
déjà c'est pour moi si vous voulez c'est
une discipline qui représente ce qu'est
l'esprit français
c'est à dire que c'est très technique
c'est très subtil et en même temps si
vous voulez c'est naturellement élégant
il ya quelque chose de très esthétique
la défense très aérien voilà et en même
temps comme dirait le professeur c'est
aussi cette rencontre que j'ai apprécié
particulièrement à anthony au club de la
route verte de paname qui est un club
donc frère d'une autre à viroflay
ce que j'apprécie aussi ce sont les deux
bouts du bâton c'est à dire que d'un
côté c'est très facile d'accès il n'y a
besoin que d'une canne pour commencer à
pratiquer et en même temps si vous
voulez il ya aussi une recherche qui
peut durer de nombreuses années pour
vraiment aller à la perfection c'est une
qualification qui précise qui est
subtile qui est pas forcément toujours
évident à apprécier dès le début est par
contre qui permet à tout le monde de
s'exprimer notamment les enfants
c'est très structurant pour le corps
pour l'adresse la mobilité la dextérité
la coordination pour les femmes au
gagnant on peut aussi pratiquer de
manière mixte c'est vraiment très ouvert
enfin moi ça m'a beaucoup plu aussi pour
surtout penser ces choses alors revenons
à l'open qui sera qui se déroulera ce
week-end à viroflay pourquoi l'organiser
à viroflay
c'est en hommage à neutre notre maître
on lire jean pierre leblond qui est
décédé il ya peu plus de deux ans qui
avait fait un énorme bras d'or française
il a été champion de france 67 100
tweets des médailles deux d'or la
jeunesse et des sports il ya énormément
de choses dit les vendeurs et donc et
antalya jean pierre est ce qu'il a fait
pour le club c'est un peu normal qu'on
fasse un gala qui porte son nom
ça prend là cette année la deuxième
édition cette année pour le deux
émissions on aura on à opter
volontairement pour moins de
d'athlètes que les dernières parties
concernées en orage avec une quarantaine
peut pas une quarantaine quarantaine de
une quarantaine mais sans compter que
pour la boxe un papa pour la can avec
l'antenne pour la boxe on aura moins de
deux pays que la dernière est indemne ou
multon aux russes et aux portugais
nous avons trois russes dont les russes
de le vice-champion du monde combat a
que pour les portugais nous aurons un
ancien champion du monde wako pro qui
est originaire française et ses français
nous aurons plusieurs champions de
france et vétérans seniors et
je trouve et vice-champion de france oui
ça m'a pas mal de gens de hbo très bon
duo de très bon niveau
dernière question est-ce que l'entrée
est gratuite parce que tout le monde
peut venir mais si nous étions
totalement mais ce sera d'ailleurs une
bonne occasion de découvrir et d'un côté
la boxe française et de l'autre la can
puisque c'est assez exceptionnel de le
voir effectivement réunies dans un seul
dans un seul et même événement
c'est une première
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau où vous souhaite bon courage
pour l'organisation de cet événement
pour rappel l'open de cannes et
programmé ce samedi à partir de 14
heures au centre sportif gayant à
viroflay
à noter également dans vos agendas en
football dans le championnat de
régionale 3 il devrait y avoir une
grande fête attrape les trappistes ont
besoin d'un match nul dans le derby
contre les mureaux pour s'assurer la
montée ce dimanche à 15 heures au stade
de gilbert gensac et pour être champion
et devront compter sur un faux-pas de
boulogne billancourt sur le terrain doni
pour réaliser cet exploit ils ont en
besoin de leurs supporters si vous
voulez les soutenir à l'entrée est libre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]